el calor abraza las ciudades chinas en
Shanghai las temperaturas se acercan a
los 35 grados por segundo día
consecutivo las autoridades han emitido
alertas mientras los residentes se
preparan para una sofocanteula de calor
tengo la sensación de que cada año hace
más calor no sé si se debe al clima y al
medio ambiente Tal vez tenga algún
impacto creo que todo el mundo debería
cuidar el medio ambiente así el tiempo y
el medio ambiente serán mejores y más
adecuados para la supervivencia humana
en los primeros días estaba bastante
fresco luego parecía que el tiempo se
acercaba de repente al verano
no hay fase de transición en medio
china ya sufrió olas de calor en marzo
especialmente en la provincia Sur
occidental de yunan donde las
temperaturas superaron los 40 grados lo
que supuso una carga para la red
eléctrica Ya que cada vez más hogares se
encendían el aire acondicionado las
provincias orientales de shandong y la
capital cententrional Beijing también
han emitido avisos de ola de calor unas
condiciones más secas podrían reducir el
nivel de los ríos lo que a su vez podría
amenazar el suministro eléctrico y dañar
las cosechas si el sector agrícola chino
se resiente los precios de los alimentos
y la inflación podrían aumentar lo que
ejercería presión sobre la economía
mientras el país intenta recuperarse de
sus años de pandemia